Before we talk about how we can implement
RVM efficiently with a back to back DRAM. Let's
first understand how we can use a back
to back to DRAM to implement a persistent file
cache. What we mean by that is, typically
file systems use a file cache to hold data
that is brought from the disk for efficiency
of manipulation by programs or anything on the processor.
And when we say it's a persistent file cache,
what we're saying is, even if there is power failure,
the contents of this file cache is still available when
the power comes back up again. And in order to
achieve that, what we're going to do is, we're going to
string a UPS power supply, to back this file cache,
which is implemented in DRAM. So the contents of the
file cache never goes away. And we also postulate that,
there is VM, a virtual memory protection. That
have been built in to the operating system to
prevent operating system errors such as wild writes
to the file cache during software crash or power
failure. Now there are two ways to use
the Rio file cache. One is, when a process
does file writes, actually they are writing to the
in memory copy of the file. Typically operating system
buffers the rights that you do to files in DRAM and then write them out to the
disk in opportune moments later on. And now if these file rights go to
the file cache which is battery backed then you make sure that
these file writes are persistent. Normally if an application wants
to make sure that when it writes a file, the contents of
the file is immediately forced disk, the application
will have to do an Fsync call in
a Unix system, for instance. But if we
have this battery-backed file cache, the application can simply
do normal file writes and don't worry about
doing an fsync, because writing to the file
writes to the file cache, and the file
cache is persistent by definition, because it is battery-backed.
And similarly, another common operation that is done is Unix allows files to be
mmaped, that is mapped into memory. And if an application maps a file into
memory and writes to that file using
normal program writes, those normal program writes
become persistent because these rights are backed
by the file cache. And the file cache
is battery-backed, and therefore normal program writes
becomes persistent also. So with the Rio file
cache that is battery-backed, what we get is that file writes by a process as
well as normal program writes to memory
mapped files become persistent by definition. In the
absence of this facility of a persistent
file cache. If an application were to mmap
a file, and write to that using normal program
rights, then it will have to do what is called
an msync call, in order to make sure that writes
that it did to virtual memory actually get persisted on
the disk. But with a file cache, real file
cache that is persistent, there is no need to do
that, because by definition, we are saying, any rights that
get into this file cache, will persist. In other words,
the contents of the file cache, will survive
power failures. So if there is a system crash,
whether it is a power failure or software
crash, the file cache data, in memory, is going
to be written onto the disk for recovery.
And so the upshot is no synchronous rights are
needed to the disk any more. It also means
that writeback of files written to by an application
can be arbitrarily delayed. What that means from the file
system perspective is that if the lifetime of files is
very short then those files go away. And so you
don't have to write it to the disk in the
first place. And this is common in compilation process for
instance a number of temporary files are created. And those
files live in the file cache for a short amount
of time and when the compilation process is complete, those files
are deleted so you never have to write those files to the disk. So that's a good
thing about having this idea of a persistent file
cache. Now let's look at how we can use
RIO to implement RVM. So we've got this persistent
file cache and we're going to ask the question,
if we have this persistent file cache, how can
we optimize the implementation of a reliable virtual memory?